Margaret Brennan is moderator of Face
the Nation and CBS News senior foreign
affairs correspondent Margaret good
morning good morning to you Anthony
Margaret how do we think Iran is going
to react now that they know that
president from ordered an attack on
their soil it but then withdrew it
well we'll have to see if that decision
to call it off actually deters Iran
because they see the president was
willing to use force or if it encourages
Iran and the kind of misbehavior you've
seen over the past few days because as
Iran has been saying they take president
Trump at his word when he campaigned
against ending costly Wars
they've been pointing the finger at his
hawkish allies for trying to goad him
into it but what Iran ultimately wants
here is to get the US to lift financial
sanctions off of it and to rejoin that
nuclear deal that President Trump pulled
out of last year what are our allies
saying about about the escalating
tension well all of our European allies
are very concerned that any kind of
strike could spiral into something else
they are also very concerned about
trying to keep that deal to keep Iran's
nuclear program under wraps in place by
next Thursday Iran says that they will
breach some limits on the amount of
enriched uranium that they are producing
essentially restart its nuclear program
and a strike would have put them in an
even tougher spot to try to negotiate
Iran away from that to get Iran to back
down so the Europeans are encouraged
that this strike is on at least hold for
now but it's unclear if they can get the
kind of diplomatic breakthrough to keep
the nuclear deal in place president
Trump is surrounded by advisers like
John Bolton known as a particularly
hawkish member of the administration how
is that influencing the debate well it's
interesting that the president defied
the more hawkish portion advice of some
of his advisers on this particular
instance but certainly the contributing
factors all the things that President
Trump says he wants to do like restart
direct talks with Iran are made more
difficult when things are carried out
like harsh rhetoric from some of his
advisors more sanctions being put on
Iran
that kind of maximalist position of do
what the US is telling you to do or else
has not paid off with Iran and Iran's
top diplomat would tell you that any
opening for diplomacy that you can see
Margaret
well the Europeans are certainly hoping
hoping that by next week they can get a
run to back off the threat to restart
its nuclear program but in terms of
those direct talks that President Trump
is offered the Supreme Leader flatly
rejected that the only offer at the at
this point Iran has made is to have
limited conversations about a prisoner
exchange and so far that hasn't been
received well by the administration all
right Margaret Brennan thanks Margaret